my entrepreneur friend Kevin David went
from working an accounting job that he
hated to in less than 18 months becoming
a millionaire using Facebook Ads Shopify
and Amazon FBA he now teaches people how
they can do the same in this video
Kevin's gonna teach us how to create a
profitable Shopify store from scratch
for beginners in a step-by-step tutorial
I hope you enjoy and there's a special
free link below to get more training
from Kevin thanks so much for the intro
Evan we're gonna just jump right into
this and I'm gonna teach you how you can
get started Shopify drop shipping with
literally no money to get started and
we're gonna reveal this secret tool that
I've taught over 10,000 of my students
to use to find viral ecommerce products
to sell to make hundreds of dollars per
day with zero money to start let's go
all right welcome to my computer so what
we're gonna talk about today is drop
shipping right how to actually make
money buying and selling products with
an ecommerce store so a lot of us have
heard about e-commerce a lot of us have
heard about you know Kylie Jenner
becoming a billionaire with her makeup
right she is drop shipping many
businesses almost all profitable
businesses drop ship in some way right
walmart drop ships Wayfarer a super
successful billion-dollar drop shipper
drop shipping has never been bigger than
it is right now and the cool part about
drop shipping is you can get started
with almost no money right because you
aren't actually but going out there and
buying a hundred products and then
reselling them right literally you are
selling a product and only after you've
sold a product then you buy it and so
this is an example of a store that sells
these type of products right so what we
can see here is you know gummy bear
nightlight magnetic cooking utensil set
all these random products so if we just
choose one of these products it doesn't
really matter what it is all right let's
just choose us so magnetic doorstop so
hidden magnetic doorstop we see that
they're selling it for 2495 so what
we're gonna do is go to another website
called all the Express and what all the
Express is is basically one of the
largest manufacturing websites in the
world but the cool part about all you
Express is you can literally buy things
one at a time and so if let's say that
this for example this was your website
so if somebody bought one of these
products right and you were drop
shipping what would happen is they would
buy it for 2495
and then
you would come on all the Express and
only after they bought it for 2495 then
you would come buy it off all the
Express for way cheaper so let's
actually type this in so we'll just put
magnetic doorstop
I mean what we can see right here is
it's two dollars and ninety five cents
for one piece right and there's free
shipping so if we literally look at
these side by side what we're gonna see
is here's the hidden the magnetic door
stop for 24.95 and this is I believe the
exact same one for 2.96 cents right two
dollars and ninety five cents so they're
literally selling it for ten times as
much and they're you know keeping all of
the profit in between which is a really
cool model but the best part is you
don't even have to buy this for two
dollars and ninety five cents until
after you've sold it already for twenty
four ninety five and then you just net
the difference you know of course - any
potential advertising fees and so it's a
really really interesting model you know
that thousands of my students have had
success with creating their own
e-commerce stores with Shopify and so
how would you actually find these
trending products how do you actually
find the bananaphone and all these like
ridiculous things like the Groot
wireless mouse and stuff like that well
there's a lot of cool websites shut up
and take my money is one but the website
that I actually use myself and that I've
taught my students to use is a website
called shop inspect and what shop
inspect does is it goes out there and it
evaluates all of the different Shopify
stores all the most successful stores
you know on all the sorts that are
getting the most traffic the least
traffic and then it'll literally tell
you based on all the traffic and sales
and all and all of those things which
stores are the most profitable so if we
come in and just search like dog collar
for example what we're gonna see is
shopper inspect is actually going to
show us a bunch of really interesting
information so we can see that you know
they have the estimated monthly searches
we can see the smart score we can see
that there's low to medium monthly
search volume with a low number of
competing sellers we can see the
seasonality we can see the word cloud
right but the cool part is we can
actually see a lot of information about
profitable products that are out there
selling on real Shopify stores so we can
see that this the water dog you know
pink dog collar is doing
$27,000 per month just with this one
product they have over 25,000 product
page monthly visitors and these you know
statistics are actually pulled directly
from sources like Alexa and some of the
largest you know website analytics
companies on earth we can also see you
know the actual social media links of
these sites we can see their real
Instagram their real Facebook their real
Pinterest we can see you know the LED
versions of these so if we want to get
product ideas you know if we're selling
a dog collar like I just like a regular
pink dog collar and it's working then
obviously if we have an e-commerce store
what we want to do is you know create
cross sells or upsells or introduce you
know additional product lines that are
similar to this product and so maybe we
went mean we might want to sell sports
dog coffee sports dog collar shocked dog
collar training collars flea collars all
of these different things that we might
not ever think about unless we use a
tool like shop inspect and we can see
here that there's LED collars there's
spike collars there's training collars
all these different things and we can
actually see if we click on this we can
see this actual product so we can see
that it's called Country Club prep this
is a real Shopify store out there that's
making you know tens of thousands of
dollars every single month we can see
the plugins that they use we can see how
they present their products right we can
see you know how they actually present
the product details shipping details
customer reviews and questions right
everything that we need when we're
creating our own store and it's really
really valuable to actually be able to
see examples of these products before we
ship it you can see right here they're
selling this for $35 and if we actually
open up all the Express one more time
and type in dog collar we're not gonna
see anything even close to $35 so you
know this is a this is a pink dog collar
right here we see a pink dog collar
right here it's not exactly the say but
it's a dollar seventy right and they're
selling it for 35 which is you know
pretty ridiculous when you think about
it but that is only one of the cool
things that shop inspect does Chaves
back we'll also look at actual store so
if we go to the shop section right here
for dog collars what we can see is
actual real stores here and we can see
the best seller
on the stores we can see you know a lot
of different things like the foggy dog
canine styles let's just look at one of
these so tact a pup right this is a
great name for a website we see tax a
pop over built dog gear so we can
actually look at these we can look at
these products current turnaround time
two to three weeks right because they're
drop shipping it they're dropped in from
China directly to their end customers
you don't actually have to ever have to
see the products touch the products you
literally ship it from Aliexpress from
Europe manufacturer directly to your end
customer so you don't have to have to
touch it see it fulfill anything box
anything ship anything out it's amazing
I'm so if we go into shop in spec we can
actually see the best sellers of tact a
pup we can see that this one product
this personalized extreme you know
tactical dog collar is doing over nine
thousand dollars in monthly revenue just
for this one products and we can
actually see you know the product
listing itself how they actually you
know do their product listings how they
do their reviews what kind of images
they use so if we want to create a
Shopify store for you know tactical dog
collars or dog collars in general what
we can do is we can see and have an
example and having an example of
successful stores it's so incredibly
important when it comes to creating
something truly special and so that is a
the product search and the shop search
but the most the the coolest part of
shop inspect if you're interested in
Shopify is the hot products section
right and what the hot products section
does is it basically goes out and finds
all the different products from around
the web and it looks at which products
are trending which products have sold
the most orders this week relative to
last week so we can see right here
vacuum-sealer food bags right these are
products that are selling you know only
370 units last week and they're selling
4511 units this week we can see that
there's a sole high-heeled Foot cushions
right so four foot four women wearing
high heels for example we actually have
a sole for the woman's foot which makes
it more comfortable and things like that
we can see that there's bandanas we can
see that there's um you know lamp chips
we can see there's Brazilian straight
hair you know I have students myself
who've sold you know millions of dollars
of
Brazilian straight hair weave extensions
which sounds ridiculous but you know
there's there's millions and millions of
people out there buying this stuff every
single day we can see warm gloves winter
knitted full finger gloves that you can
use with your phone it looks like we can
see you know shredders all these
different types of crazily random
products and the cool part is you know
we can see that you know last week there
was only 1100 orders of this and this
looks like a dash cam for people's cars
and this week there's 13,000 749 orders
which is a huge increase and so let's
say that we wanted to actually import
this into our store and start selling it
all we have to do is favorite it come to
my favorites and then we can literally
download these products and upload them
directly into our Shopify store in two
clicks able to actually start selling
these products which is really really
incredible when it comes to creating you
know an e-commerce store and being able
to get your products first to market
because the first people the first
people who get to market are normally
the ones who capitalize on these trends
and this is literally showing you viral
products before they actually become
viral all right guys I hope you enjoyed
that quick look into how to start making
hundreds of dollars per day using
Shopify drop shipping Evan thanks again
for having me Evan does have one more
thing to tell you guys so make sure you
check it out Kevin is having a free
webinar training to take you deeper and
show you step-by-step how you can make
more money if you're interested in
checking it out the link is in the
description below and if you want
Kevin's advice on how to sell an Amazon
FBA check their video right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there I'm
gonna teach you the step-by-step
strategies that I've taught over 10,000
of my students how to create a
profitable Amazon business in just three
steps let's go